cool yeah II know that sounds like a
compliment like yeah somebody in some
sort of chip animation studio oh really
right said let's draw a cute cool Asian
guy and they made you
you don't look necessarily and don't
take this the wrong way human right yeah
you your forehead is exposed in the
right of way
perfect but still unusual uh-huh right
your nose it's just definitely created
and some sort of lab so cute it's a
[ __ ] piece of candy Japanese candy in
your [ __ ] face you want to eat yeah
your eyes are like unusually like once
Quinny once not that twenty right just
listen to me man this one is estimate
ISM that's yeah what does that mean that
means I can't see very well out of this
one so what happened not just a sickness
genetics that means like it's not like
round that's not an ancient joke but
yeah I was not perfectly round yeah but
that's why it's cool you can even tell I
go yeah I like that right now we gotta
[ __ ] after I probably wouldn't you you
went for not his type not really my type
now yeah if cuz I was if I was gonna go
get gay yeah I would probably have to go
um
the Steve Byrne type make Tony thermo I
mean who wouldn't right like who won one
rise deeper yeah yeah yeah I probably
wouldn't [ __ ] him just but like his type
it's time you know like twenty Thornburg
you know twenty throws look it up later
- straight - no sweet is the sweetest
Chinese like a Henry that that what's
that guy's you know what I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna give you a
photo of him Henny Penny what is there
any pennies Daniel Henney oh yes yeah
look at half-asian half-white guy who's
that oh my god oh yeah oh really
ya know would you [ __ ] Daniel heady if I
was gay yeah yeah even how about like
just as a fund I know that you're
straight but for fun yeah
do I want to do it yeah I don't I don't
think so I don't know about that so this
is the guy right here there's a 23rd
Berg and I would do gay love to him like
and now and yeah now even when you're
straight and he's a half asian okay
that's good looking [ __ ] man I
mean be real dude you know I mean look
at that look he's just like good morning
yeah why's your belly exposed was my
mouth on your dick he's also a wizard at
times what does he do as an actor no
he's a [ __ ] male model dude and it's
like and he knows about me he knows that
I have a man crush on him you know I
gotta make some how does it look like
that man like but you but could I be
honest with you and I don't want you to
take this the wrong way I keep saying
that and then half way insulting me go
ahead this is what I want you to do
because you're you're on a right on the
right path right now okay I think after
armed Silicon Valley you'll get a
network then you know it'll be great and
the thing is is this is that and then
you know the higher you go in the
business you you you get exposed to
higher numbers of women right you need
like a six-foot to swedish blonde model
mm but that's you know you're gonna have
to do that to have good-looking kids to
have Tony Thornburg yeah no I don't
think so
right now I'm in like five ten and then
six feet tall yeah yes how are you I'm
five six right yeah so how do you know
like if you no offense to her but
Melissa McCarthy yeah right yeah yeah
like if you had made love to her and you
had a kid with her uh-huh you know I
mean it'll be good looking kid she's
like a woman yeah it's not gonna be a
twenty you don't like comedy geniuses
basically I don't think our kids are
gonna come out very cute I'm just being
real with you yeah but they're gonna
have issues but they're gonna have um
inward talents but we're not worried
about like who
is about looks who cares when you're
like when I'm probably just said that if
you wanted to get a twenty Thornburg oh
yeah yeah that's what he needed to do
I'm not saying that maybe maybe just a
Steve burn burn you're gonna have to go
hi I need a look at Steve ARS parents
because his dad is a tall white guy
first of all he's the white one when the
father's the white one
yeah it Jeff for summer is it
genetically it works no that's [ __ ]
though well that's just how it is that's
80% is the father's the white one right
we have no we have no examples of it
hold on was your same old couple I'm
gonna be a white guy in order for the
Jeanette have half of your parents DNA a
sperm and an ovum I want a somebody in
this room right now okay that was a
dumbest thing I've ever fought I am
about to [ __ ] prove me wrong with
[ __ ] legitimate evidence uh-huh right
give me a male Asian model that the dad
was Asian I don't know any male agent
Pony Thornburg Daniel Henney is he Henry
Golding who's the lead of crazy rich
Asians oh yeah yeah is he half he's half
I don't know come look um of his parents
all right and if you give me factual
things then I can go okay I just don't
think you've seen them that much cuz
eight out of ten are the data yeah but
that's circumstantial it's not it's not
because genetically it's gonna you know
they have a propensity you look like dad
like that's right you just don't see
that many white tigers out there yeah I
mean they don't exist okay well you know
what guys
um I could be wrong and that's what
living life is like you you you you you
say sir so you don't believe that if you
procreate it's gonna be a nice-looking
kid well with her yeah if it looks more
like her then we're like okay we're
doing okay but if it kind of leans
toward me we've got a problem especially
if it's a girl but okay
there is hope because his brother is
very cute brother has like softer
features is like you know but those huge
features the Reacher's no no the reason
why my features are the way they are
okay is because of all the drug use and
also all the eating but if I lost a
bunch of weight uh-huh I shaved my
mustache I took shower you have a
picture of you at your optimum Prime
like I don't know when your looks good
alright steroids but yeah I like how old
though I don't know your prime man yeah
25 no if I have any Prime photos mum
[Music]